hallo mein name ist meine lieben freunde
diesen tollen oder irgend zu kaufen wir
haben uns allerdings nicht versammelt
für werbung sondern meine lieben freunde
die sich bereits im titel eingeblendet
ich reagiere heute auf die strengsten
eltern der welt also auf die kabel eins
serie und ich witze angeregt mit dem
ersten clip
papenburg im emsland in der 35.000
seelen gemeinde geht es eigentlich
finde ich auch schon einmal wie die da
stehen ja komm stell dich mal die mutter
nach vorne stellen wir die tochter nach
links und den typen mit seinem karl kani
shirt nach rechts der 14 jährige thomas
und die 16 jährige sarah ganzen ihrer
mutter elke auf der ich finde die serie
sollte nicht die strengsten eltern der
welt halten sondern die bescheuerten
kinder der welt deshalb sollen sie die
nächsten zehn tage bei einer strengen
gastfamilie in kanada erleben
kanada ich würde gern weil nach kanada
und die werden da hingeschickt als
bestrafung aber gut mit der lieben
freunde das ist allerdings nicht der
einzige klub bin ich vorbereitet habe
sondern dass hier ist der nächste ich
glaube dass handelt von diesen kevin
pascal schon oder pascal kevin aus hamm
ist auf pascal kevin habe ich ja vor
einer woche schon mal reagiert als ich
meine reaktion auf positive hoch geladen
habe und der passt kevin der ist auf
jeden fall eine tickende zeitbombe
pascal kevin aus hamm ist eine tickende
zeitbombe
mein reden wenn du mich sich
zurückzukehren was meine lieben freunde
in meiner bester war sicher faul
reaktion habe ich nicht weiter darauf
reagiert weil das sei der einzige
ausschnitt war der aus diesem video
genommen wurde
allerdings machen wir das ja dann jetzt
jedes telefon klingeln ist für sie ein
alarmsignal
ihr geliebter sohn steckt mal wieder in
schwierigkeiten
[Musik]
was
egal wann das telefon klingelt immer ist
angeblich was mit kevin pascal passiert
alles klar dass kein kind keine regeln
und keine grenzen nicht ein
stadtschule henkers kaliber mit kumpel
ceylan kippen und wir schon am frühen
morgen das ist der alltag der
sonderschüler
[Musik]
die mutter sagte auch da mal nervt dich
was du das weißt du was würde das für
muss morgens in der schule
ja also ich kann den kevin pascal auch
voll verstehen allerdings kommen nun zum
nächsten clip bin ich vorbereitet habe
und zwar spielt er in wendeburg die 16
jährige sina ist der albtraum jeder
mutter ihr zimmer lässt die
hauptschülerin verdrecken regeln sind
ihr vollkommen egal mein die sitzung
hatten schwänzt ständig den unterricht
und strafen auch schon drauf legen
ich glaub ein teil davon war auch schon
in der best-of-three action aber schauen
wir uns jetzt mit diesen kompletten drei
minuten clip davon an eine freundlich
gucken auf den klang eher nach merkels
vorstellungen ganz normal am
montagmorgen
also schauen wir zwar jetzt auch chinas
zwölfjähriger bruder rahim leidet unter
den täglichen gewaltausbrüchen seiner
großen schwester
[Musik]
von tag zu tag schauen sich dann die
sachen
und dann kommt halt im moment dass ich
komplett aus
[Musik]
das blut dann wenn man geschwitzt hände
da die mutter die 16 jährige kennt keine
skrupel wenn sie geld für alkohol
zigaretten oder partys braucht bin
klatschen ihre mutter sorry aber
irgendwie sie hilft wir wie die
strengsten eltern der welt nur ein neuer
wenn ich immer auf ablaufdatum gucke das
ist halt vor sechs jahren hochgeladen
worden ck und hilf mir ist dann
irgendwie so der remake wäre weniger
stadt jung pleite verzweifelt was halt
früher die strengsten eltern der welt
also irgendwie kommt das schon relativ
nahe zusammen einstellung nur eine bank
geht und der typ sagt nun also eine
million euro kriegen sie nicht dann
würde ich mir auch einfach nehmen und
ein banküberfall staaten für die
schulschwänzerin gehören alkoholexzesse
zum alltag
trinken bis zum umfallen welcher ein bis
zur besinnungslosigkeit okay das ist
allein allein das bisher auch die sache
wo du dir das alle alkoholika eigentlich
immer champagner beziehungsweise sekt
trinken weil er am krassesten und
beziehungsweise am schnellsten ballern
und instant suche meine mutter jetzt um
drei uhr nachts an
ich kann doch nicht abholen
ich bin in köln nicht in bielefeld auf
viel erfolg noch
du kannst du uns abholen
aber das hier ist ein supertolles fox
soccer es gibt zu kaufen können
dann musste mich meiner straße aufgabe
nur zwei freunden von mir dass ich gar
nichts mitbekommen was ich meine da
gewissen form klar ist es lustig sich
jetzt irgendwie das hier anzuschauen und
zu denken guck mal die ist irgendwie 13
14 und trinkt was ist mit der falsch und
es ist ja alles nur geschauspielert aber
es gibt wirklich familien wo dass der
tägliche alltag ist und ich will mich
doch überhaupt nicht krass darüber
lustig machen weil ich glaube es gibt
wirklich familien die mit sowas krass zu
kämpfen haben mit solchen situationen
aber hier ist natürlich alles rein
geschauspielert also ich möchte hier
keine person irgendwie angehen oder
irgendwann beleidigen oder keine ahnung
was allerdings kommen wir nun auch schon
zum letzten die strengsten eltern der
welt tipp den ich vorbereitet habe
die schlägerei und jetzt machen die da
in so ein kugel hege sauber nico nice
weiß dass er die teenies nicht völlig
umkrempeln kann deswegen gewährt er
ihnen kleine laster um sie zu motivieren
ach so das sind schon zwei teenies die
nicht mehr zu hause leben also ist jetzt
nicht so einen clip von wegen hey das
ist falsch mit ihnen und jetzt schicken
wir die irgendwohin sondern die sind
schon ihr gehirn geschickt worden dass
wir diesen großen oder polen oder keine
ahnung was da gesprochen hat und müssen
so bau arbeit leisten auf dem bauernhof
und irgendwie kriegen die sich jetzt
wollen die köpfe glaube ich war ich
würde es dir du hast also abgefangen und
beim lagern holst du aufzuarbeiten
blatter da wird deine fresse elternhaus
keine zigaretten kaufen ich ziehe
einfach gar nichts das nicht okay dann
sag ich ja nicht ahnen gar antwort
[Musik]
eskaliert dass doch jetzt gleich so
richtig ein paar sekunden später o mein
gott
julia will ein für alle mal klar machen
wer hier das sagen hat und verliert die
kontrolle
gerade hier trägt sie auf ihn druck sie
geht auf ihn los das hilft mir ist es
halt so ja da sieht man den von vielen
szenen sowie dann lachen irgendwie und
keine ahnung was und dann merkt man ja
auch das gespielt was man weiß auch dass
es gespielt dass aufgrund von interviews
mit den darstellern aber hier gerade
wirkte schon sehr krass als wäre das
nicht inszeniert worden
ich habe mich irgendwie schlag eine
mädchen
ich kann mir das nicht mehr anschauen
von daher bin ich an der stelle des
heutigen wir jetzt auch beenden wir
lieben freunde wird euch meine
reaktionen hierauf ein paar ausschnitte
von die strengsten eltern der welt
gefallen hat dann auch gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video oder
schreibt mir gerne und in die kommentare
ob ich noch mal auf diese serie
reagieren soll
schreibt mir zudem auch gerne die
kommentare ob ihr wisst ob das ganze
gespielt ist oder an einigen stellen
auch nicht weil ich bin mir nicht mehr
so sicher
falls sie noch kein teil der luxus sein
würde ich mich allerdings auch sehr
freuen wenn ihr meinen kanal abonnieren
würde unter dem video ist ein knopf ist
kostet unsere verpasst keine videos mehr
berner oberland zeit gehen auch die
glocke verpasste keine videos mehr und
bekommt halt keine benachrichtigungen
neues video online geht und wenn ihr
wieder sehen wollt wie ich auf leute
reagieren die anderen leuten ihre kippe
ins gesicht schmeißen und sich dann
boxen auf einem russischen bauernhof
also wenn das kein argument das alter
nicht petrus
[Musik]